[Music]
you may not have been exposed to the new
coronavirus but you've almost certainly
been exposed to an adjacent contagion
maybe you've even helped spread it I'm
talking of course about social media
about the post that we see on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter some of which will
come from news organizations or
qualified medical professionals but a
lot of which comes from ordinary people
on the street expressing their fears and
posting photos of empty supermarket
shelves where there should be for
example hand sanitizer this is a new
phenomena ten years ago the last time we
had a pandemic fear with the swine flu
Facebook had just 360 million users fast
forward to 2020 and has 2.5 billion
according to the Pew Research Center 57
percent of Americans think that the news
they see on social media is largely
enacted it means the people when they're
fed information to social media aren't
entirely sure what they can trust and
that makes it hard for medical
authorities to cut through the noise
when the Spanish flu took hold a hundred
years ago it wasn't called the Spanish
flu because it originated in Spain it
was simply that that is where the first
reporting happened in any great depth
news the virus wasn't initially widely
reported in the UK US France of Germany
partly it's a hangover from the
censorship of the First World War
there's a strand of social thought
called contagion theory which looks at
the way that ideas spread sometimes
irrationally in large groups some social
theorists assert that the way social
media works is by exploiting our
emotions Facebook invites you to respond
to a post with an emotion like love
laughter
amazement anger crying these are
emotions the abroad cast out your
followers and invite them to do the same
the effect of posting a picture of
people queuing to buy toilet roll or
hand sanitizer is similar you're
prompted to ask yourself whether you
should be doing the same it's addressing
you on an emotional rather than a
rational register nobody is going to
shut Facebook down nor should face
posting blocky photos that might
accentuate the planet but we as
individuals do need to think carefully
about whether the content we're posting
is helpful or whether it's just beach
force and
I couldn't be more proud of the efforts
of the men and women standing behind me
or all of those standing behind them
President Trump said from early on that
this would be a whole-of-government
approach and today gives evidence of the
fact that it is also a whole of America
approach we're bringing the full
resources to the federal government and
the full resources of of this great
economy and our great business sector to
bear in protecting the American people
and protecting American families a few
updates from today as we continue to
expand testing availability across the
country testing is now available at all
state labs by the end of this week there
will be more than 4 million more tests
made available in jurisdictions around
the country 1 million are already in
place thanks to the good work of our top
commercial labs that the President Trump
brought together yesterday
LabCorp and quest are in the process now
of distributing and marketing
coronavirus tests all across America and
we're working with state and local
officials to ensure that that happens as
rapidly as possible but as the testing
is expanding we wanted to make sure the
American people knew that testing was
available to them and that cost would
not be a barrier today President Trump
assembled the top health insurance
executives in America and as we
announced earlier today all of our major
health insurance companies have now
joined with Medicare and Medicaid and
agreed to waive all co-pays cover the
cost of all treatment for those who
contract the coronavirus they've
committed to no surprise billing and
they've committed to encourage
telemedicine it was a year ago that
Medicaid actually expanded to pay for
telemedicine Medicare pays for
telemedicine so now for seniors who may
think that they are either at risk or
have contracted the disease they can get
medical advice
without having to go to the doctor or go
to an emergency room I know I speak for
President Trump when I say how grateful
we are to see our health insurance
industry step forward to meet this need
so that that no American should be
concerned about about being able to pay
for or for the cost of a coronavirus
test if they deem and their doctor deems
it to be appropriate and necessary
president also went to Capitol Hill
today to meet with members of the United
States Senate Republican caucus there he
talked about an economic package
including a call he's calling for
payroll tax relief and I think most
important to the president's heart we
want to make sure that hourly workers
hard-working blue-collar Americans that
may not have paid family leave today
that small and medium-sized businesses
in America would be afforded the
resources to provide paid leave so that
no one would feel that they have to go
to work if they might be infected or if
they might have been exposed to the
coronavirus we had a good reception on
Capitol Hill our legislative teams have
fanned out we're going to be working
with Republican and Democrat leadership
to move an economic package Larry Kudlow
will be reflecting on that in just a few
moments we also talked about what are
known as n95 masks and we're working
senator Deb Fischer and others have
important legislation that would extend
temporary liability protections so that
masks that are made for industrial use
could be sold to hospitals to ensure
that our health care workers are
properly protected and outfitted and
we're grateful for growing bipartisan
support for that measure and we're gonna
be working earnestly with Republicans
and Democrats to move a reform that
would make more n95 masks available I'm
also pleased to report that we did
receive this afternoon a comprehensive
proposal from the cruise line industry
proposal that includes advanced
screening improving medical services on
ships providing for airlift evacuate
and land-based care at the expense of
the cruise lines for anyone that might
be an not only infected with the corona
virus but with any serious illness we'll
be reviewing that in the next 24 hours
the president's objective is for us to
make a Cruise Lines safer even as we
work with the cruise lines to ensure
that that no one in our particularly
vulnerable population is is is going out
on a cruise in the near future I'm gonna
recognize doctor foul Qi to talk about
where we are and dr. Burks will give us
some research that she's done on the
scope will have other updates but let me
say once again this is a
whole-of-government approach and from
early on president Trump has insisted
that our that our government at the
federal level all of our partners at the
state level work in concert to protect
the American people and as we stand here
today the risk to the average American
of contracting the corona virus remains
low but we're absolutely determined to
give every American the tools and the
information that they need to protect
themselves their families their their
workplace their schools and and we're
going to work together we're going to
work together to see our way through
this and and working with leaders in
both parties in Congress working with
with leaders at the state level all
across this nation I'm confident we will
with that dr. Tony Fauci for an update
on the status thank you very much mr.
vice president just to give you a very
brief sketch of what we do every day the
cases continue to increase globally we
potentially paying particular attention
to the cases in Europe and Italy in
France in which we're starting to see
that up at the same time as the relative
number of new cases come down from China
what we're seeing in Europe is that
Europe is in that up slope so that's
something that is expected that's the
way these kinds of outbreaks go this is
not a surprise to anybody if you look at
the history of infectious diseases
outbreaks in the United States we
continue to have
cases as of this morning they were 712 I
believe with 27 deaths guaranteed by the
time of this evening that's going to be
up and there'll be several war and
tomorrow there'll be several war so we
realized that this is something
obviously that we've been saying all
along that we're taking very seriously
now the question is what are we gonna do
about that and there are a number of
things that one can do in order to blunt
it if you look at the curves of
outbreaks you know they go big Peaks and
they come down what we need to do is
flatten that down that would have less
people infected that would ultimately
have less deaths you do that by trying
interfere with the natural flow of the
outbreak so what we're saying today is
that although we keep coming in and
saying appropriately that as a nation
the risk is relatively low there are
parts of the country right now that are
having community spread in which the
risk there is clearly a bit more than
that and you know the places you know
Washington State
California New York and Florida but what
I want to talk to you about today just
for a moment or two is that we would
like the country to realize that as a
nation we can't be doing the kinds of
things we were doing a few months ago
that it doesn't matter if you're in a
state that has no cases or one case you
have to start taking seriously what you
can do now that if and when the
infections will come and they will come
sorry to say sad to say they will but
when you're dealing with an infectious
disease you know we always have that
metaphor that people talk about that
Wayne Gretzky you know he doesn't go
where the puck is he's going where the
puck is going to be well we want to be
where the infection is going to be as
well as where it is so what we have here
you could say that here what it's here
is that if you go to coronavirus gov
remember when dr. Burke's yesterday
mentioned some of the things that we put
together these are really simple
keeping the workplace safe keeping the
home safe keeping the schools safe and
keeping commercial establishing safe
this should be universal for
country everyone should be doing that
whether you live in a zone that as
community spread or not when you have
community spread you obviously going to
ratchet up the kinds of mitigations that
you have but at a minimum this is the
minimum that we should be doing so
everybody should say all hands on deck
this is what we need to do so I'll stop
there and later I'll be happy to answer
questions Thank You mr. president and
thank you dr. Falchi for that clarity we
continue to monitor the situation across
the country and across the globe and we
are very fortunate between dr. Falchi
and I we have long term contacts out
there and many of these countries that
are experiencing current outbreaks we
continue to review all the scientific
literature to look for insights and to
really determine who's at the greatest
risk and that's why we've talked to you
about people with immunodeficiencies at
any age people with medical conditions
and the elderly and how important it is
for all of us that take these
precautions in the household to protect
others because we have circulating flu
and other respiratory diseases at this
time we all have to act like all of
those diseases any respiratory disease
can be transmitted to others and as we
said yesterday we're hoping that
decreases all the respiratory disease
were experiencing finally we got more
new reports out of China who had nine
pregnant women I'm during an acute kovat
infection and all nine were infected
both and they delivered while they were
infected and all nine babies were
healthy and the mothers were healthy so
we continued to look for data like that
to be reassuring to the American public
at the same time ensuring that every
single person is participating in this
response to this virus and taking those
precautions that we should be taking
every day if we start doing this today
we will be ready next year for any of
our respiratory diseases because I think
we'll be able to show that these simple
simple household simple work simple
school simple business approaches across
the country can change all of our
respiratory diseases so we thank you for
getting the message out we thank you for
the participating and ensuring
your households and our households
around America that we're protecting all
of those who need our support right now
thank you dr. Burks and dr. Falchi and
this information is available at
coronavirus gov and as we said we can't
say often enough the risks of
contracting the corona virus to the
average American remains low but for
senior citizens with serious underlying
chronic health conditions the potential
for serious consequences is very real
and make no mistake about it by
practicing these habits in your home
your school and your business you're not
only protecting your health but you're
also protecting those that are most
vulnerable with that for an update on
our the progress the President Trump
made today with our health insurance
companies I'd like to recognize see as
Seema Berman the vice president said we
had a terrific meeting with the
insurance companies a real example of a
public-private partnership where they
agreed to waive co-pays for testing not
do any surprise billing and also cover
the costs of the Cova virus associated
costs the other things that they did is
they asked the president for more
flexibility in Medicare Advantage plans
and the president agreed to do that and
so today we issued guidance to our
Medicare Advantage plans that not only
can they waive the costs for the tests
but they can also go further to removing
pryor off there's authorization
requirements they can waive prescription
refill limits they can allow for mail
delivery of prescription drugs and
expand more access to telehealth
services if they weren't offering that
in their plan also at CMS we continue to
work with health care providers around
infection control practices we met with
home health agencies and also hospitals
and today we issued guidance to dialysis
facilities as well as home health
agencies around infection control it's
been a great deal of attention about the
Grand Princess and HHS working with the
Coast Guard with the Department of
Defense is currently working through
disembarking American passengers
returning from foreign nationals to
their country and I wanted to ask the
secretary SAR to speak and update us on
the progress thank you so with regard to
the Grand Princess I wanted to first
express our appreciation to governor
Newsom to the mayor of Oakland the
people of Oakland the longshoremen the
stevedores who have helped with bring it
in and clearing the clearing the dock
area so that we can do all of our
operations there
we've got Admiral Abel here with us
today who's been leading the Coast Guard
efforts and then Deputy Secretary vigan
from state has done incredible work with
our foreign partners to help with the
repatriation of their nationals who are
on board the ship as of our data that
I've got is as of noon pacific time
today so this will have increased quite
substantially since since my last update
but as of noon pacific we had 548
individuals who have been offloaded from
the ship 228 Canadians are already back
in Canada flown there I believe was
overnight 171 Californians were taken by
the government of California and are now
at Travis Travis Air Base 26 individuals
were sick and they're being they're
being treated for various it could be
from the novel coronavirus that could
also just be had some frail individuals
who are sick that needed treatment our
goal is to get all of the citizens of
California off today to be in the care
of the key of the California state
government as well as to get the UK
citizens off today so that they could be
repatriated to the United Kingdom we
continue to work with other countries on
all of those maneuvers we will have non
California residents who will be in
transport to the bases at Dobbins and at
Lackland today we hope that or tonight
so everything is progressing it seems to
be progressing well we're using the
highest isolation quarantine procedures
medical screenings possible to ensure
the safety of not just the passengers
but also of the the local communities
and all of the health care workers and
others emergency responders are helping
so thanks to all of our partners for
this their help with this very complex
operation
good report and let me echo the
Secretary's appreciation to governor
Gavin Newsom the state of California the
City of Oakland it has literally been a
seamless partnership everyone on that
ship will be tested isolated and
quarantined as appropriate and provided
with treatment the crew on the ship
other than those who were ill will be
quarantined on the ship offshore but it
really represented the kind of
partnership and cooperation from every
level of government that every American
I know is grateful to see with that on
the economic front alert Cutler thank
you sir hi yesterday in a meeting in the
Oval the president acknowledging there
going to be challenges on the health and
economic side he mentioned that he
intended to bring the full power of the
federal government to deal with these
challenges and accordingly as vice
president said up at the Republican
Senate luncheon today and he mentioned
it in this room yesterday President
Trump has unveiled his proposals strong
proposals for a temporary payroll tax
cut holiday which I think he would
prefer to last through the end of the
year also administrative Lee as Treasury
secretary minutiae and others have
suggested we are trying to we will use
assistance to unpaid sick leave people
very important point also small and
medium businesses another important
point and also possibly to some
distressed industries or sectors in the
economy may be tax deferral might be a
useful tool and other means so this is
strong cross the board package we are
consulting with leaders in the House and
the Senate with respect to this package
and particularly the payroll tax holiday
let me just say coming into this
difficult period
the economy isn't fundamentally good
shape we saw blockbuster jobs report
last Friday today for example the small
business confidence index the NFIB
business confidence index registered a
very strong number keeping its near
record high the unemployment remains low
at three and a half percent other
indicators look pretty good we had a lot
of momentum in the first quarter good
thing I recognized the challenges and
that is why we are proposing these
fiscal measures to combine with monetary
measures that have already taken and
again I'll repeat the president's words
it just struck me as his determination
he intends to bring the full power of
the federal government to deal with
these health and economic challenges and
a word from Surgeon General Jerome Adams
good evening everyone as Surgeon General
whether it's opioids or cigarettes or
the corona virus my job is to help the
American people understand how to live a
healthy life and I'm asking all of you
I'm imploring all of you to help share
my prescription for America to overcome
this coronavirus situation that we're in
there are three parts to it number one
know your risk as you've heard many
times but it's still important to
impress upon America if you are
immunocompromised if you have chronic
medical conditions if you are over the
age of 60 you are at higher risk if you
are a child or a young adult you are
less likely to be impacted by the corona
virus number two the second part of the
prescription no your circumstances are
you in an environment where you can
telework are you planning on going to
large gatherings like Church do you live
in a community that is being
particularly impacted by the corona
virus and you can find out this
information from your state or a local
health department does your state have a
hotline that you can call in to to help
you assess symptoms again knowing your
circumstances then number three and this
is the most important part know what you
can do to stay safe and
we have really leaned into coronavirus
gov I please send people to that website
we've put the tools on there for
individual groups specific audiences so
that people can understand how to say
sticks stay safe if we follow this
prescription we will we will overcome
the corona virus as dr. Falchi said we
will see more cases unfortunately we are
likely to see more deaths we have not
hit the peak of this epidemic quite yet
but if we follow this prescription then
we will decrease the number of people
who were impacted we will decrease the
number of people who will die and we
will more quickly get to the end of this
situation thank you so we'll the Pens
Trump campaign suspend campaign rallies
and other activities I think that'll be
a decision that's made literally on a
day to day basis I thought dr. foutch
you spoke to that yesterday very well
that we're gonna I'm very confident that
the campaign will we'll take the very
best information and make the very best
decision going forward but these
proposals are are things that every
American can do all across the country
that that will reduce the risk of either
contracting or being exposed to the
coronavirus the word unveiled was just
used but so far the public has not seen
it how big is this package how big is
the payroll tax cut
when is the general probably gonna see
with you all put together right learn we
were working out details right now so I
don't want to quote any numbers ahead of
time you know you make a proposal we're
checking with the leaders of both
parties in both houses and see what is
doable and where the you know tough nuts
are gonna be so I don't want to get into
any detail
I think the outline of the thing is very
important the payroll tax holiday is
probably the most important powerful
piece of this but on the other hand I
want to draw attention we can use
administration and executive authority
again to help unpaid sick leave people
which is very important we can use it
for the medium and smaller businesses
which is very important other distress
sectors we have some leverage on tax
deferral if we know I mean look I will
say again as I have for quite some time
the economy is strong we also know
they're gonna be problems ahead we know
they're gonna be challenges it don't
deny it
we'll see I want to take that a day at a
time and in fact at a time a statistical
release at a time but anyway this will
be the broad package and at some point
in the in the near future we will
outline a more detailed package for you
the president proposed to the GOP policy
lunch today to remove the entire payroll
tax from both employers and employees
that would be a twelve point four
percent reduction back in 2010 we had a
two percent reduction can you basically
eliminate four however number of months
the payroll tax without blowing it's
huge
the budget in furthermore the president
told the Munchie he'd like to make that
cut permanent how do you do that
you know the payroll tax holiday is a
bold move it's a very bold move and this
has always been a bold president and
we've been cutting taxes and rolling
back regulations and changing trade
deals and opening up the energy sector
and doing things that nobody thought we
could do before John we've had pretty
good economic results for it we're in a
challenge period now I get that so with
respect to your question on the
specifics I think there'll be a big a
big growth payoff I think it'll help
deal with whatever challenges occur in
the next few months I think beyond that
ameliorating the tax burden on the
middle class the so-called blue-collar
boom that I talked quite a bit about
that's what this is aim for that's
really what the payroll tax is
principally about by lifting the burdens
of those middle-class folks I think
we're gonna get a big growth kicker
we've had a terrific ly strong labor
market as you know it may stall a bit or
not I'm just speculating on the on the
challenges of the unhealth side but I
think over time we'll make it up with
much better economic growth and I will
remind also that later on way down the
road probably later this summer early
fall we will unveil another package of
tax cut and tax reform proposals but
yeah it's a bold proposal and this is a
bold president and I think it's paid off
I mean you're 21
Social Security unemployment insurance
and Medicare Part A revenues are 1.2 3
trillion dollars I just say we're not
talking about Medicare at this point I'm
gonna by the way the answer is yes you
can backfill it and that has been done
before because we've had other payroll
tax cuts and you mentioned one of them
in 2010 or 2011 so the answer that is
yes and the answer is we will always
maintain a solvent Social Security
system but you know tax reform is very
important economic growth is very
important incentives for middle and
lower-income workers are very important
that I will just add you know in terms
of the boldness of this president's
policies despite what some of our
critics think actually it's the middle
and lower middle people that have done
the best in wage growth terms and I
think this is absolutely consistent this
lifts tax burdens on the middle class I
think it's absolutely consistent with
his earlier policies let me also say
John if I can that the other piece of
this is is what the doctors have said to
us what the experts have said is if
you're sick if you have reason to
suspect that you may have coronavirus we
want you to stay home and the
president's absolutely adamant working
with the Congress or using his executive
authority to ensure that that hourly
workers people working for small or
medium-sized businesses that don't
currently have paid family leave what
will be able to stay home and be
confident that they're not losing a
paycheck I think every American can
identify with that concern and and we
we're going to work forward whether we
do it legislatively or the president has
some some some resources in his
executive authority to act we're gonna
work to make sure that that hourly
workers don't feel like you have to go
to work sick because you're risking a
paycheck get home stay home take those
couple of weeks to get better
Thank You mr. vice president I want to
drill down on something that Larry just
said though because in 2018 according to
the Center for Buzz's Budget and Policy
Priorities federal payroll taxes
generated 1.1 seven trillion dollars
it's an enormous figure Larry you're
suggesting that you can make that up
from general revenue where are you going
to get a trillion dollars from you know
let us put the proposal out in concrete
details and flush that out and we'll
have much better answers right now I
want to stay in my lane and I think the
health story the coronavirus story is is
very very important here we will do the
best we can even to give you specific
plans and details once we flush them out
increased testing capacity we're going
to fill state reports of severe
rationing in many cases because of the
limited supply it appears to be close to
impossible for average Americans to get
tests without being hospitalized first
so when can the American people expect
to see these test kits available at
doctors offices as Urgent Care admitted
clinics that sort of thing specifically
well I'm gonna have the secretary step
forward and address that but let me say
we've made great progress over the last
week and million tests are in the field
every state lab in America can do
coronavirus tests if you if you're
concerned that you have corona virus
your doctor can contact the state lab
can have a test processed by the end of
this week another four million tests
will be distributed but to your very
important question we're working day by
day with the largest commercial labs in
America we had we had some good
discussions today with outside experts
as well who said that when the president
brought the commercial labs in he did
exactly the right thing because it's
those big companies that have logistics
infrastructure all over the country have
labs all over the country that can
distribute the tests process the tests
whether it's quest or whether it's lab
core and we believe that in the days and
weeks ahead we're going to continue to
see the availability of tests
dramatically rise and we're driving
toward that every day mr. secretary do
you want
maybe dr. Redfield can add in also um so
by the end of this weekend we had 1.1
million tests that were actually shipped
we have another 1 million that are
either in transit or waiting for orders
so we actually have a surplus capacity
already of tests that have been produced
and as the vice-president said by the
end of this week be another 4 million
tests so the tests are out there the
tests are in every public health lab in
the country they're in hospitals they're
in labs but I think there's a false
premise in your question which is the
notion that just because I as a person
say oh I'd like to be tested for the
novel coronavirus I should be going to a
minute clinic or some other facility and
just walking and saying give me my tests
please that's not how diagnostic testing
works in the United States or frankly
almost anywhere in the world if their
doctor will always be clear if their
doctor or public health physician
believes they should be tested it needs
to always be clinically indicated to
receive a test so it's a false premise
go to your doctor if you first actually
don't go to your doctor call your
doctor's office if you believe you may
have the novel coronavirus call the
clinic call the hospital call the
doctor's office so that you don't just
walk right in follow their infection
control procedures for doing that and
then they will decide working with you
whether a test is appropriate to be done
but there are millions of tests out
there now and it's gonna as the
vice-president said with quest and
LabCorp getting it at the doctor's
office swabbing that their distribution
and transport system it's going to be an
even better closer to the patient
experience as I promised I talked to you
on Saturday when we met together that's
very good and answer I'm gonna ask dr.
Burks to speak to this too because she's
just done a tremendous job bringing our
commercial labs to bear on this but to
your other point the president directed
us to essentially change that the
criteria that CDC was giving labs around
the country
we heard from governor's around the
country that people that were only
mildly symptomatic were being told that
they couldn't be tested we changed that
we changed that description and so as
the president said anyone who on a
doctor's order wants to be tested can at
a doctor's indication be tested now
we're working to fill that need and if
we're making great progress every single
day but I wanted dr. Burks to speak to
the talk yeah I just wanted to talk to
you briefly about what happened in
decreasing barriers I've I've been a lab
person I've been a vaccine developer
I've been a doctor I've been all those
things but I've never in my lifetime of
government service have worked with the
CDC in a way that every time the state
or local government calls and says I
have this barrier I need a modification
to the regulations that has happened
almost daily and the reason we have
commercial labs willing to step in
immediately is because the FDA has
created that ability and posted on their
website I don't know if you've been
there this unbelievable waiver system
and the clear definitions there every
single hospital every single University
can utilize this testing algorithm and
that's highly unusual but it's also
what's bringing this super large
high-throughput companies to the to the
table and I just wanna this has been
unique for me to be able to see this
unbelievable dialogue between what
states need what local governments need
and federal government being responsive
with changing those regulations and that
has been really wonderful to watch
how do the success of the travel ban on
China and Iran why has it not extended
those bans to South Korea or Japan or
Italy and is it still under
consideration when it has the
administration really shifted to
mitigation from containment well I'm
gonna let I'm gonna let dr. Burke speak
to that in a moment
but there is no question as dr. foutch
you said just a few days ago we would be
in a very different place if President
Trump had not suspended all travel from
China and we've been also I suspect be
in a very different place if we hadn't
issued travel advisories for portions of
Italy portions of South Korea and
initiated screening of all passengers on
all direct flights into the United
States from both of those countries I
will tell you we had a very we had a
very thorough discussion today of the
prospect of recommending to the
president additional travel advisories
what we're doing particularly as dr.
Fauci said is we're following the facts
and and we're going to bring those
recommendations forward in the time and
manner that we as the White House
coronavirus task force determined are
appropriate but let me tell you it is
literally a day-to-day consideration and
we're going to continue to put the
health and safety of America first dr.
Burks did you want to amplify that or
thank you sir a boxer who used to be a
part of this administration said that
two days before could be overrun he
recommended that schools be shut down
the administration think about that
doesn't agree that we u.s. could be at
the point where there could be a turning
point in the next ten days or so and
what about well let me say the
recommendations that you have and that
every American now has at coronavirus
gov apply to every jurisdiction in the
country every state in every community
irrespective of whether or not there's
been a corona virus case established I
will tell you that we're working very
closely with California Washington New
York Florida to develop community
specific recommendations for those areas
where we have had what is known as
community spread a number of coronavirus
cases that appear that it's being
transmitted in the community in the next
24 hours working with those states we'll
be publishing CDC's recommendations for
what ought to be done but I want to turn
it over to dr. pouchy to tell you that
we really think the most important thing
here is that we continue to bring the
facts forward to the American people and
that in that our proposals and our
recommendations well well all of these
apply to everybody in the United States
and it'll help reduce the infection rate
of the corona virus that for those
communities that are being impacted
we're going to develop specific
recommendations that'll make the most
sense for them dr. pouchy
whether is it can you wait until there's
community spread to make some of these
well it depends on the degree of
community spread I mean community spread
could be just a small amount or you
could start to see multiple generations
but getting to your individual
individual questions that everything is
on the table for consideration so the
idea that we're not closing oh I mean I
think for the country right now to say
we're gonna close all the schools in the
country
I don't think wouldn't be appropriate
with school closures the appropriate
depending upon not whether you have
already the horses out of the barn but
when you start to see we're getting a
little bit dangerous so let's do it so
it's incorrect to say now everything has
happened bad let's close the school and
it's incorrect to say let's just blanket
closed the schools in the entire country
tonight I don't think that that would be
appropriate but I do think it would be
appropriate to carefully try and do
things like closing but there's other
things besides closing to do real
mitigation some time before you think
you really need it that gets back to
what I said a few moments ago about
where the puck is going to be but you
want to make sure you're not so far
ahead that you overshoot aramony a few
moments ago on this sign up here it says
you should stop and shaking if you're at
your workplace and you're in your school
or in commercial establishments should
the president set that example I notice
you've been opting for the elbow bump
well look as the president has said in
our line of work you shake hands when
someone wants to shake your hand and I
expect the president will continue to do
that I'll continue to do it what what
this is is a broad recommendation for
Americans but a really good
recommendation is to wash your hands
often and and that all the experts tell
me that while while people want to want
to get the various
sanitizing lotions washing your hands
with hot soap and water 20 seconds is
just as good as any lotion you can buy
response with all the countries I'm
sorry say if you're not plan to
coordinate our response with other
countries either continent president
truck met president from Brazil whoa
Sanada this weekend did they talk about
coronavirus I know that they spoke about
a broad range of issues and I'm
confident the coronavirus was discussed
what I can tell you is that our focus is
on the health and well-being of the
American people we're going to continue
to communicate with nations across this
Hemisphere and across the country but
what the president's given us as a
mission of the White House coronavirus
task force is to see to the health and
well-being in the American people and
will continue to make recommendations to
do just that how about one more
questions one on Washington State they
made a request a strategic stockpile for
a base of 2 233,000 baths and they
received half of that wondering if that
report is inaccurate that please speak
to it and secondly on Cruise Line
I are you looking at a bailout for
cruise lines at several of these
companies or a taxi percent so so they
got half of the shipment from the
strategic national stockpile initially
and then when the Vice President
actually went out to the state of
Washington that's when the second half
of the shipment arrived but I have
spoken directly with Governor Inslee
with whom we've had a superb working
relationship and he has informed me that
there are some additional personal
protective equipment needs that a couple
of there hospitals have and we're
working through the strategic strategic
national stockpile to make sure we are
directing and fulfilling shipments to
them as needed
I want to echo again our gratitude to
governor Inslee and and all the health
officials in the state of Washington I
was there last week our teams are
working very closely together we'll
follow up on that public report but the
secretary is indicated but look we're in
as I said in the next 24 hours
we will be working with not only
Washington State California with New
York with Florida and and unveiling our
recommendations CDC's recommendations to
those areas that have been impacted by a
community spread and then we'll continue
and to come alongside those communities
to do everything in our power to
mitigate the spread but let me just say
again as a resource thank you all we'll
be back here again tomorrow coronavirus
gov practical information for every
American details for state labs that may
yet have questions about performing
their own tests we have specifics
enzymes agents ingredients that that
where they can be acquired and how for
the performance of coronavirus tests but
for every American I just want to say
again remember that well the risk to the
average American of contracting the
corona virus remains low but however the
risk to senior citizens the serious
underlying chronic health conditions is
very significant and it's important for
all of us to continue to take all the
steps necessary to look after the most
vulnerable to look after our health and
I'm confident that we'll get through
this together
you may not have been exposed to the new
coronavirus but you've almost certainly
been exposed to an adjacent contagion
maybe you've even helped spread it I'm
talking of course about social media
about the post that we see on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter some of which will
come from news organizations or
qualified medical professionals but a
lot of which comes from ordinary people
on the street expressing their fears and
posting photos of empty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the last few days in the oil market have
been extraordinary nothing else that
historical we have seen Saudi Arabia
increase in production to a record high
immediately Russia responded doing
exactly the same and we have seen some
of the biggest price drops the oil
market has ever seen the oil price war
started when Saudi Arabia tried to cut
oil production to offset the impact of
the corona virus outbreak that is having
on oil demand Russia refused to cut
production and the response of Saudi
Arabia was well if we are not going to
cut production and we are not going to
live oil prices and I'm gonna increase
my production to try to make up for the
revenue loss of low oil prices and that
has had a massive impact on the oil
market at one point the oil price drop
by 30 percent in one single day that was
the largest oil price fall in one day
since the Gulf War in 1991 the price war
is a massive diplomatic pour curve game
and on the table we have bloody meat
Putin of Russia Mohammed bin Salman of
Saudi Arabia and Donald Trump of the
United States and most of them are going
all-in in this poker game who is gonna
win it's gonna depend know as much about
who can produce the biggest pain to the
others but who is the one that cannot
absorb the pain and probably they're the
weakest of all the three is Saudi Arabia
the US traditionally has benefited for
low oil prices after all low oil prices
means low gasoline prices and consumers
love low gasoline prices the problem is
that the u.s. also is a big oil producer
they are the shale revolution in Texas
New Mexico Oklahoma and North Dakota and
those oil companies need high oil prices
so when prices go down it means less
drilling less unemployment in the
industry and also a loss of revenue for
many states the stock market is going to
suffer because oil companies represent a
big portion of the stock market so we
can see consumers paying less at the
pump but at the same time the same
consumer suffering because the pendulum
fans are going to suffer
[Music]
you may not have been exposed to the new
coronavirus but you've almost certainly
been exposed to an adjacent plantation
maybe you even helped spread it I'm
talking of course about social media
about the post that we see on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter some of which will
come from news organizations or
qualified medical professionals but a
lot of which comes from ordinary people
on the street expressing their fears and
posting photos of empty supermarket
shelves where there should be for
example hand sanitizer this is a new
phenomena ten years ago the last time we
had a pandemic fear with the swine flu
Facebook had just 360 million users
fast forward to 2020 and has 2.5 billion
according to the Pew Research Center 57%
of Americans think that the news they
see on social media is largely inactive
it means that people when they're fed
information to social media aren't
entirely sure what they can trust and
that makes it hard for medical
authorities to cut through the noise
when the Spanish flu took hold 100 years
ago it wasn't called the Spanish flu
because it originated in Spain it was
simply that that is where the first
reporting happened in any great depth
news the virus wasn't initially widely
reported in the UK US France or Germany
partly as a hangover from the censorship
of the First World War there's a strand
of social thought called contagion
theory which looks at the way that ideas
spread sometimes irrationally in large
groups some social theorists assert that
the way social media works is by
exploiting our emotions Facebook invites
you to respond to a post with an emotion
like love laughter
amazement anger crying these are
emotions that you broadcast out to your
followers and invite them to do the same
the effect of posting a picture of
people queuing to buy toilet roll or
hand sanitizer is similar you're
prompted to ask yourself whether you
should be doing the same it's addressing
you on an emotional rather than a
rational register nobody is gonna shut
Facebook down nor should face those be
blocking photos that might accentuate
the panic but we as individuals do need
to think carefully about whether the
content we're posting is helpful or
whether it's just feeding the frenzy I'm
Alex Webb for Bloomberg News and I'm
hoping this isn't just contributing
you may not have been exposed to the new
coronavirus but you've almost certainly
been exposed to an adjacent contagion
maybe you've even helped spread it I'm
talking of course about social media
about the post that we see on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter some of which will
come from news organizations or
qualified medical professionals but a
lot of which comes from ordinary people
on the street expressing their fears and
posting photos of empty supermarket
shelves where there should be for
example hand sanitizer this is a new
phenomena ten years ago the last time we
had a pandemic fear with the swine flu
Facebook had just 360 million users
fast forward to 2020 and has 2.5 billion
according to the Pew Research Center 57
percent of Americans think that the news
they see on social media is largely
enacted it means the people when there